jour 1 de la campagne électorale avec un
très bel exemple de ce que ça veut dire
le hors champ
[Musique]
voilà c'est dit sue dit le lieutenant
gouverneur et donc c'est mais non ça
commence c'était le défilé ce matin à
québec pour le dernier conseil des
ministres
hélène david parle de projet de société
quand soudain gaétan barrette arrive
dans le champ lui qui perdrait le
ministère de la santé au profit de
gertrude bourdon
d'abord pressenti à la caq françois
legault cherche maintenant un bon
gestionnaire pour la santé ou en anglais
top nach manager mais ils sont distraits
derrière improvisation dans 3 2 1 et ce
qui change à québec solidaire c'est
qu'il y à un autobus cette année j'y
pense que je vais être très fiers d'être
débarqué de stopper cette région enfin
il y a le choix du cadre pour lancer une
campagne l'église de beloeil est
parfaite en arrière plan c'est ce qu'on
appelle le chant le contre chance
derrière la caméra
ce que jean françois lisée avait devant
les yeux c'est un salon funéraire
le grand clac et donne rendez vous sur
le chemin de la grammaire si mathieu
prost radio canada montréal